man I tell you what I love the holidays
I love Christmas
I love the generosity round Christmas I
love being a grandpa at Christmas I love
being around family at Christmas I hate
being around the calories at Christmas
because I take them all in and now I
have to work them off and I know you
didn't do that but I'll tell you what
man that this this this beginning of a
new year I know it's something that's
quote man-made int meaning that we have
a calendar that we've observed the Stars
and the rotation the Sun and the moon
and etc and we came up with a calendar
and we get our you know we didn't come
up with it but we observed it and and
but the beginning of a year is a it's
something we it's in our brains you know
what is still a fresh start you still
get a whiteboard you didn't do
everything you want to do like you
wanted to do it in the last year you
won't do everything perfect this year
you can go and give yourself some grace
in advance but you know what you ought
to try you ought to try there's a quote
that is attributed loosely to st.
Augustine that says pray like it depends
on God like it all depends on God and
work like it all depends on you and so
you know it's time to do both it's time
to make your life better it's time to
make the life of your family better it's
time to make the life of your church
better it's time to make the life of
your community better it's time to make
the life of your nation better and you
have something to say about that you're
not a victim you are not being
controlled by outside forces some of you
are scared to death that Donald Trump is
coming into office some of your glory
bouncing off the walls that Donald Trump
is coming into office and truthfully I
am coming into office has about 1% to do
with what happens to your life unless
you're going to be working for him you
are in charge of your life and I want
you to go win I want you to
down tonight if you haven't already done
it and lay out some detailed goals not
not New Year's resolutions some detailed
goals and you know you need to look at
financial goals you look at intellectual
goals I mean books are you going to read
this year how many classes are you going
to take family goals are you gonna do
something different with your family
this year spiritual goals so you need to
ramp up your church attendance don't you
your Bible reading physical goals some
of you need to lose some weight and get
in better shape some of you want to run
a marathon for the first time in your
life a half marathon some of you want to
do I don't care but you need to do this
on purpose it's not you don't get to the
end of your life and say wow that
accidentally occurred most of the things
that happen in your life or things you
planted in the ground and they grew a
harvest in your life and if you don't
plant anything in your field called your
life you know what grows weeds you
become an expert on The Bachelor you
become an expert on who got thrown off
the island you become an expert on
everything that Fox News or CNN says you
don't put anything intentionally in your
brain that affects your life going
forward you need career goals some of
you need to make more money and that
doesn't accidentally occur just showing
up you know some people have 20 years
experience some people have 1 years
experience 20 times they don't learn
anything they don't get any better they
don't grow in their career you need some
social goals you need to intentionally
decide to engage some folks in your life
on a social basis friends my granny
always used to say if you want to have
some friends maybe you ought to be a
friend your goals in order for them to
work they need to be 5 things and you
need to write these 5 things down so
you'll know that your goals are working
number one and number two they need to
be specific goals and they need to be
measurable goals I want to lose some
weight this year you won't that's
measurable but it's not specific
I want to lose 30 pounds good now we're
going somewhere I lose 10 pounds I lose
28 pounds I don't care what it is
I want to read I want to read more books
this year you won't
how many more books do you want to read
be very specific it needs to be
measurable needs to be specific your
goals need to have a time limit as soon
as you put a time limit on something
that you are specific about then the
long division from sixth grade kicks in
I'm going to read 12 books this year oh
instantly you know that's one a month
don't you and that's 1/4 of a book every
week isn't it yeah you know and write
that down you need to have them in
writing put your goals in writing if you
don't write it down it never happened
that's true about contracts and it's
true about goals a lot of people have
goals and New Year's resolutions I say
them they don't write them down when you
write them down is when they happen you
know write down I want to make more
money great how much more this year and
then write it down and then start taking
the steps as to what you're going to do
for that to work so goals that work must
be specific they must be measurable they
must have a time limit they must be in
writing and they must be your goals
they're not goals I give you they're not
goals your mother gives you your wife my
wife wants me to lose a little weight
you won't unless you're just a complete
wuss you do everything she tells you to
do and then even then it will stick you
won't do it my husband always wanted me
to be thinner yeah probably but that's
not going to cause you to be thinner
think about it they need to be your
goals you have to want to pay the price
to win and there's always a price to be
paid when you're going to win you have
to be sick and tired of being sick and
tired you have to reach the point that
you say that's it I've had it I'm not
living like this anymore
I'm not going to try to fit in these
jeans anymore I'm going to get that
weight off I'm not going to wait around
to write my book this year I'm going to
write it I'm not going to
hello around in this victim mentality
anymore I'm going to spiritually address
my life and change my connectivity to
God you have to do it intentionally they
has to be your choice I can't do it for
you I want you to be out of debt some of
you though I want you to be out of debt
more than you want to be out of debt why
do I want you to be out of debts cuz
then you'll build wealth why don't you
build wealth because then you can change
your family tree and take care of
yourself and bless others without
rageous generosity and have a
high-quality life and get to live your
dreams and travel and do some of the
things that Sharon and I have been
blessed to do I'd like for some of you
to get to do that but you're going to be
specific and measurable have a time
limit and put it in writing and
emotionally owned the goal yourself has
to be your goal that's how you start
your your people right there you can do
this changes everything when you do put
it down in writing sit down and I turn
off the stupid television not making you
any money you're watching other people
make a good living it's not helping you
get thinner you're sitting there getting
fat watching TV
seriously make a decision what are you
going to do this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
you
Oh